(speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] And here they come stomping
straight into the base of Kentucky.
- [Voiceover] Robert Morris
University in Chicago
has recognized that esports is massive,
with over 130 million people tuning in
around the world to watch
digital athletes compete.
That's why they're the first US college
to offer varsity gaming scholarships.
Now, there's a whole new
kind of jock on campus.
- My name is Kurt Melcher,
I'm the executive director of esports
at Robert Morris University.
I really come from a
traditional athletic background
but I've also at that same time always been
in love with video games.
That's when it hit me that
we could offer scholarship
and get the best League
of Legends players,
and run it the same way as
we do any of our athletic programs.
Some of the technical requirements
to have varsity level is
definitely is bandwidth specific.
We work closely with our IT department
to make sure that we would have no lag,
no issues with Internet.
I think they doubled our
bandwidth for the university
just to make sure that we're not gonna
be overloading the system,
and, you know, affecting other classrooms.
(upbeat music)